in Dessau-Roßlau in Sachsen-Anhalt steht
seit mehr als 200 Jahren das Schloss
Georgium dort ist die berühmte
anhaltesche Gemäldegalerie untergebracht
eigentlich der nach einer jahrelangen
Sanierung des Gebäudes können die alten
Meister nicht mehr aufgehängt werden der
Grund die Stadt bekommt das Klima in den
Ausstellungsräumen einfach nicht in den
Griff also ich halte das für ein
Armutszeugnis für die Stadt das über
viele Jahre hier nichts passiert und das
kann man nicht mehr akzeptieren im 18
Jahrhundert haben Gemälde Galerien
funktioniert und im 21 Jahrhundert
kriegen wir das Klima in den Räumen
nicht hin 2010 beginnen die
Sanierungsarbeiten des historischen
Gebäudes schnell ist klar es wird länger
dauern und sehr viel teurer werden aus
den ursprünglich geplanten Kosten von
1,5 Millionen Euro werden 15,5 Millionen
doch als das Schloss 2022 wieder
eröffnet werden soll gibt's die böse
Überraschung in den Ausstellungsräumen
stimmt das Raumklima nicht mit der neuen
Klimaanlage gibt es Riesenprobleme erst
ist es zu trocken dann zu warm nun zu
feucht das Schloss bleibt geschlossen im
Rathaus von Dessau-Roßlau will man von
einem Planungsfehler nichts wissen die
baulichen Gegebenheiten des historischen
Gemäuers sein höchst kompliziert gewesen
schriftlich heißt es daher erfolgte der
Einbau einer teilklimaanlage für die
geringere bauliche Eingriffe notwendig
wurden unter diesen Bedingungen war es
technisch sehr kompliziert die
notwendigen Klimawerte zu erreichen und
diese konstant zu halten wir hoffte
Lösung eine zusätzliche
Entlüftungsanlage auf dem Dach der
aktuelle Zustand ist für den
Vorsitzenden des anhaltischen
Kunstvereins und tragbar
das das für den
Kulturstandort Dessau aber auch für
sachsen-anhalt-katastrophe ist das
sozusagen die die Zugänglichkeit zu zu
den Gemälden nicht gewährleistet ist
dass das Gebäude seit nunmehr 13 Jahren
geschlossen ist dafür haben viele
Menschen kein Verständnis
man hat das vielleicht kaputt saniert
damit und man hätte sich vorher Gedanken
machen müssen das war ja schon lange
genug geschlossen und jetzt bloß wegen
irgendwelcher klimap Probleme das nicht
wieder aufzumachen die müssen doch
lösbar sein wann das Schloss Georgium
wieder eröffnet wird konnte uns von
Seiten der Stadt niemand sagen nur so
viel man arbeite mit Hochdruck daran was
immer das bedeutet